in A Song of Ice and Fire Milla Sondra
the red prices of ash I has never seen
without her golden choker which contains
a large Ruby at its center throughout
the books is hinted that the necklace
may be more than just a simple piece of
jewellery it seems to be if not the
source of her power then a great tool in
which she uses in order to work her
spells and sorcery what are the uses of
Milla Sandra's Ruby
Melisandre and her Ruby first appear in
the a Clash of Kings prologue around her
throat was a red gold choker tighter
than any maces chain owned a minted with
a single great Ruby we get the first
hint that the ruby may be more than just
a stone
when maester Cressen questions the power
of her God guns make uncertain allies at
best
the old man insisted and this one has no
power here
you think not the Ruby at Miller
Sandra's throat caught the light as she
turned her head and for an instant it
seemed to glow bright as the common he
does have power here my lord the woman's
egg and via cleanses at her throat the
Ruby shimmered readily the Ruby is
shimmers and glows as Melisandre speaks
of her Godwin lore trick of the light
perhaps or perhaps not when Milla
saundra is at the wall with Jon Snow he
notices that she's not wearing first to
protect herself from the cold
you'll not cold my lady she laughed
never the Ruby at her throat seemed to
pulse in time with the beating of our
heart the Lord's fire lives within me
Jon Snow heal she put her hand on his
cheek and held it there while he felt
how warm she was this is how life should
feel she told him only death is cold
so Jon Snow notices that Melisandre
seems underdressed and immediately the
author draws our attention to the
pulsing ruby that seems to imply that
the ruby is providing Melisandre with
inhuman resistance to the cold in the
books the ruby seems connected to the
glamouring of mance rayder and the Lord
of bones when the Lord of bones has
burned in place of Mane's and glamour to
look like him
Milla saundra can feel the heat of the
jewel on her neck when the flames had
licked rattle shut the ruby at her
throat had grown so hot as she feared
her own flesh might start to smoke and
blacken thankfully Lord snow had to live
in her from that agony with his Arabs
when Milla saundra summons the glamoured
mance rayder to her quarters at the wall
she can feel the ruby as he comes near
to her Milla saundra felt the warmth in
the hollow of her throat as her ruby
stood at the closest of its slave she
refers to mance as the slave of the Ruby
and not her slave in my opinion that
implies that the ruby itself is the
source of the glamour later when she
breaks the spell Milla saundra touches
the ruby on her throat then the ruby on
mantas arm goes dim and the glamour
vanishes the sound echoed queerly from
the corners of the room and twisted like
a worm inside there is the wildling
heard one word The Crow another neither
was the word that left her lips the ruby
on the wild Lynx wrist darken and the
wisp of light and shadow round him rive
and faded in the show it's revealed that
Melisandre is a lot older than she looks
and it's later stated by the producers
that she's hundreds of years old in both
the show and the books after removing
the Ruby in the show the glamour
vanishes and she's revealed not to be
young and beautiful but old and feeble
this aligns with everything we know from
the books we know from the books that
she has practiced her art for years
beyond count and paid some price for it
and we know from the books that rubies
are essential to Milla Sandra's
glamouring spells the Ruby being the
source of her glamour in the show fits
too can far better than the idea is that
her appearance is due to the loss of
power or the loss of faith in ruler
Melisandre's ruby is definitely
responsible for our youthful appearance
and it appears to be the reason she can
resist the cold but could it be
responsible for anything else
milah sandra also has no need to eat and
barely has any need to sleep in the show
when she removes her Ruby she then gets
into bed as it to sleep this supports
the idea that her Ruby is responsible
for her lack of sleep as well the word
Ruby actually comes from the Latin word
Ruger which means read Milla Sandra and
the books is referred to as the red
woman or the red witch that also seems
to suggest that the Ruby may be far more
significant than a simple tool according
to real world legend the Ruby's red glow
comes from an internal flame that cannot
be extinguished I would be shocked at
George our Martin was not aware of this
when he made this character being that
the Ruby is present during all of her
spells I don't think it's a huge leap to
consider that it may be the source of
her power entirely the Ruby represents
fire within which is exactly what
Millicent reclaims for God provides her
with she's never seen without it and the
author draws attention to it over and
over throughout the books it mentioned
nearly 20 times in advance with dragons
alone even though Mila saundra only
appears in John's chapters and one POV
chapter of her own all the evidence that
we have suggests that the Ruby is the
source of Millis Andres power the
question then becomes where did she get
it from hopefully we'll get the answer
in the winds of winter thank you guys
for watching make sure you subscribe for
more ideas of Ice and Fire
you